ام
[موسيقى]
ودع القيادى الاخوانى محمد كمال السنانيري
في سجن استقبال طره ضمن معتقلي قرارات
التحفظ في شهر سبتمبر ايلول عام الف
وتسعمائه وواحد وثمانين
وفي الرابع من شهر نوفمبر تشرين الثاني من
ذات العام اعلن عن وفاه السنانير داخل
السجن جاء في تقرير مباحث امن الدوله ان
السنانيري قد لقي حتفه من تحرك بعد ان
شارك نفسه في دوره مياه السجن فهناك وجده
حراس السجن جثه هامده واحد شقي وجهه مناطق
لارضيه الحمام المبتله
هذه الروايه اكدها لنا اللواء فؤاد علام
الشخصيه الاكثر جدلا في ملف وفاه السلام
والذي كلف اثر اغتيال السادات بمواجهه
المؤامره التي اودت بحياه رئيس الجمهوريه
بالتاكيد امني لان لما يصير القضيه
انتحاره واه بدات ا جمع المعلومات عن هذا
والمستندات اكد لي انهم اه اه المستندات
اللي اولا الطب الشرعي اثبت انتحار
وبالتاكيد بانه رابط ولايه في الصيف
[موسيقى]
ونزل القران اسوا من فوق ال
ول استيضاح اكثر حول تفاصيل الانتحار
توجهنا الى الدكتور جمال شقره رئيس قسم
التاريخ الاسبق في جامعه عين شمس والمختص
في تاريخ جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
الامن بياكد انه
سنين كاتب على الحائط انه يا اساس من الحل
لانه هذا الساعه الى على هويته
لما صوروا ال ال الان كاتب
تشريعات انه خطوه فعلا خطى كمان سنين
كمان سمير
من قرارات الرئيس خلاله خمسه
ضمن الذين شملهم قرار
التحفظ ولذلك اه منزل المدعي الاشتراكي
وتحقق معها في المدعي الاشتراكي وينقل
زميله في المدعي الاشتراكي وهو بين بين
الوهم للتحقيقات اه حجم التنظيم الذي تعرض
له ان المتوقع اننا
توجهنا الى الطبيب عبد المنعم ابو الفتوح
النزيل المجاوره زنزانه السنانير في سجن
استقبال طره لنستوضح من اكثر حول اسباب
وظروف الاعتقالات التي حصلت في اواخر عهد
السادات
ذهاب السداد لاسرائيل ثم اتفاقيه كامب
ديفيد تسعه وسبعين شكل الصدمات
الاتجاهات السياسيه كلها دون استثناء
وبالذات الاتجاه الاسلامي
وبالتالي صار حاله غضب شديد ضد السادات
السادات وجد بتفكيره القاصر انه مع هذه
الاتجاهات بها في السجون فتره الى ان
تنتهي اه عمليه ال اتفاقيه كامب ديفيد
وبالتالي قرر ان يتحفظ على الف حوالي الف
وستمائه واحد الف خمسمائه وخمسين من كل
الاتجاهات
[موسيقى]
الجماعه كانت في تعزيز عهد السادات او
18 لما تعرض له اي تعذيب انما تعزيز بدي
اكون فى عهد مبارك استمر موجودين في
استقبال تورا دون اي زيارات ولا اي اتصال
لكنها المعمل داخل السجن معتمدين على اكل
السجن وعلى لبس السجن فقط حيث لا غير
مسموح يدخل ملابس ولا طعمه ولا ادويه ولا
زيارات لكن المعامله من اداره السجن
المسجونين اه كانت معامله محترمه ومعذبه
الى ان تم اغتيال السادات
كانت كل المعلومات المرشحه وقتها عند
الاخوان متورطين في هذا الموضوع من الملف
الجهاد داخل جماعه الاخوان المسؤول عنه
الاداء القتالي اه كمال السنانيري السادات
قتل باداء قتالي رفيع المستوى في داخل مع
كان لابد اي مسؤول امني يجيب كميه ان
يتحقق ما
قالت الاعتقالات و عام الف وتسعمائه وواحد
وثمانين نخبا شخصيات مهمه ومؤثره في
المجتمع المصري ومنهم جمال الدين
السنانيري حيث كان قياديا بارزا في
التنظيم الخاص لجماعه الاخوان المسلمين
واحد تلامذه حسن البنا مؤسس الجماعه و
شخصا فاعلا في العديد من الملفات الخارجيه
للاخوان المسلمين في سبعينيات القرن
الماضي الاستاذ جمال السلامي الى الله
يرحمه كان
ضمن مجموعه التنظيم الخاص على الاخوان
اللي كانت موجوده الاستاذ البنا كان من
ضمن زعماء هذا التنظيم والمبرزين في جدا
يكاد يكون على درجه اولى او متقدم في
وجوده في هذا التنظيم او في المجموعه
معالي الاستاذ مصطفى على على الحج احمد
حسنين كما غريب اه في فتره عبد الناصر
واستمر
وعدد من الاخوان على مدار عشرين سنه تقول
اربعه وخمسين دولارا واربعه وسبعين
تقل ثلاث مرات يعني مره او هنيه في اي قبل
ايام الثوره
الاخوان ثمانيه واربعين بعد حل الاخوان
الامر الثاني
اربعه وخمسين اربعه وخمسين على تعزيز جدا
جدا جدا الامر الثالث الاعتقاد تمكن من
ايام ال اه الرئيس الراحل انور السادات
الشهيد كمال سنرى الحقيقه من الرموز
المهمه في جماعه الاخوان المسلمين رغم انه
نقدر نقول
في مكانه قياديه اه مركزيه في جماعه لكنه
كان رمز وكان الاستاذ كرم للسنين بالنسبه
لمجموعه الاخوان المعتقلين هو كبير هم هو
اللي كان يتحدث مع اداره السنه
[موسيقى]
ام
بعد وفاه الرئيس السادات ابتدت الامور
تظهر انه سيتم الافراج عن كل المعتقلين
والكلام بحث ال اكتوبر واحد وثمانين
فالناس كلها كانت بتاهل نفسها انه
المعتقلين خلص على قاب قوسين او ادنى من
الخروج يعني فوجئنا في نوفمبر
واحد وثمانين بردو بخبر وفاه في الصين
سعينا للوصول الى تقرير الطب الشرعي الخاص
بتشريح جثه الثانيه واوضحت لنا مصلحه الطب
الشرعي ان التقارير الصادره في عام الف
وتسعمائه وواحد وثمانين تم اتلافها بعد
مرور المده القانونيه عليها
طبقا لما ورد في التقرير بالشارع المدخل
هيدي كانت واضحه خلال نفسها اودى
التقرير لكن هو ذكر انه هو اه اه اه اه
توجهنا الى احد ضباط مباحث امن الدوله من
الذين كانوا يشغلون منصبا في مصلحه السجون
ابان وفاه السنانير في الحصول على تقرير
النيابه العامه حول ملابسات وفاه السنانير
في السجن ابلغنا الضابط انه لم يجد
التقرير وبعد محاولات عده استطعنا الحصول
على ملف تفريغ افادات الراحل محمد شوقي
السنانيري الشقيق الاصغر محمد كمال
السنانيري اثناء تحقيق اللواء فؤاد علام
معه حول واقعه وفاه محمد كمال السنانيري
وظروف استلامه للبعثه
مما جاء في افادات شوق السنين في وصف جثه
محمد كمال السنانيري لدى استلامه لها
الفتح تشهده والتخطيط بتاع اللي كان واضح
في الحاجه اللي كنا فيها وانت حربها الله
على والادخار اعوام تخيطين بردو بوجود
الاخ احمد
اللي جايز علشان واخذوا عينات
ما فيش اسمه اثار تعذيب غير الحده اللي هو
شنا نفسه بها في الرغبه
كما وجدنا في الافادات ان تقرير اياب قد
ارجع سبب الوفاه الى الشرق من قبل المتوفي
كانت المعضله التي واجهتنا امام سبب
الوفاه هي شهادات نزلاء سجن استقبال طره
حول تصميم بناء السجن ودورات المياه فيه
والتي لا تسمح بتنفيذ عمليه شعور
انه عمل
مليئه ربطها في
الحوض اه يعني بصرف لا يمكن عمليات
الانتحار
او بالتعليق تتم الا في شيء مرتفع الانسان
يربط
او يربط فيه شيء ثم ينزل وتوافر يقف على
شيء اسمه يعني اه يقذف نفسهم على كرسي
الادوات الانتحار اللي بال بال اه غير
متوفره اصلا غير مسموح بيك نكتبها موجوده
معك
فكيف سينتحر
حتى من الناحيه الطبيه انا كرجل طبيب
توجهنا الى لندن بلقاء الدكتور ابراهيم
منير القيادى البارز فى جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين ورفيق السنانير في السجن في
الخمسينيات
لعلنا نجد عنده تفاصيل اوفى من الروايه
الرسميه للوفاء ان يقال انه اه اه انتحر
بان وضع في رقبته اه او شيء وفي اه اه ال
اه اه
نسبه تضامن
ايديها شيء مرتفعه لا تردع متر ونصف فانت
حر الطريق وضعهم واه اه يعني اليات سعد
بني حتى اختلف لا يمكن ان تحدث لا فنيا
ولا يمكن على الاقل قبل ان يصير حاله
الاختناق ممكن ان تدلي يعني
على نفسه
الموت هو علامه
الاعلام يعني هو كان
هو لما 2 وخبر من واحد غير دقيق بانه
ربطوا هو ربط ال رابط الملا بتاثير الكوع
ال ال ال مش عارف الحمام اه الروايه ممكن
تكون من واحد من الدقيق لما صح ها طلع انه
هو ربطوا في الشباك
ام
ان اناجيل سكني استباق ترى غيره مره يعني
روح
موقف اقسم فيه استاذ اه اه زنازين دي
بس
حاجه عليه
مع تضارب روايات الانتحار عمدنا الى اعاده
جميع احداث الساعات الاخيره من حياه
السنانيري قبل وفاته من جاور والتقوا في
السجن فكان الطبيب عبد المنعم ابو الفتوح
هو اخر من التقابه سببا فرنسيين الاستقبال
في الوقت ده كان كان معروف من سجن القلعه
اللي اصبح متحف حرب دلوقتي او متحف هو
السجن الذي تديره مباحث امن الدوله في
الوقت ده من اجل التحقيق والتعذيب واصبح
بعدما اغتيال السادات سيدي يا ضيق
بالمطلوب التحقيق معهم او او تعذيبهم او
او فكان القرار اللي اتخذ في جهاز الامن
ان يوفر سكن استقبال عمليات التحيات
قبل حنا ما نقل كلنا بيوم او يومين
اه اه اداره السجن طالبت الاستاذ كمال
الثمانيه اللي هو الوحده وكان مساءا
وخرج حتى انا بسيط من الشراء
وقلت له يا استاذ كمال
عليه اللي انه كان طلع باغلبيه بسيطه ترجع
وقد اه اه اه
عليه باعتبار الوعد ماكنتش عارف يروح
ويرجع وذهب او لم يعد
[موسيقى]
ام
وانتقلنا على
عشان عايزين يفضل السيده عشان يجيبوا
الناس اللي قتلوا السادات واللي هما
تعاطينا في تعزيز كما هو يعني يعني وحده
مدى التعذيب او نوفمبر كان بيعملوها تحقيق
من تعد اشتراكي
من صفر
يعني
وواحد
فقال له الكلمه خطيره اوي قالوا في يعني
في سيدني
مستقبل ترى في مذبحه وهذا ما المح باربعه
وخمسين
بما ان الوجهات الاخيره ل لسنا نير قبيل
وفاته كانت غرفه التحقيق وفقا لل شهادات
السابقه فقد شفنا البحث لمعرفه هويه
الضابط الذي استدعى السنانير يوم وفاته ان
يسمع منه ملابسات احداث ذلك اليوم ومما
زاد من صعوبه مهمتنا ان اللواء حسن ابو
باشا مساعد وزير الداخليه للامن العام عام
الف وتسعمائه وواحد وثمانين والذي يعين
الضباط المسؤولين عن التحقيق مع سجناء
استقبال تورا قد توفي في عام الفين وخمسه
حاولنا التواصل مع اللواء محسن السرساوي
الذي شغل منصب مامور سجن استقبال طره
اثناء احتجاز السنانيري لمعرفه هويه
الضابط الذي اوكلت اليه مهمه التحقيق مع
السنانير الا انه رفض اجراء المقابله فمن
الذي حقق مع محمد كمال السنانيري
يوم وفاته
اللي كان مسؤول عن السجن في الوقت ده
بيكون لتاكيد هو اللي هو فؤاد على كانوا
كل ما بحث امن الدوله وانا عرفت احنا ما
مرت داخل هذا السجن وانا قلت لمستشفى
استقبال ترى لما طلبت منهم ان تعمل الشعب
الصدري على الكل عشان كان عندها توماس كان
قالوا مش احنا اللي بيقرر هذا احنا والسيد
اللي هو فؤاد على الاب والام لا نعرف ان
الامور السجن
قال فؤاد علام هو نوع من الدوله المسيطره
على السجن في المائه سواء من حيث
التحقيقات
حيث نقل للمسيحيين من حيث السماح لهم
بالخروج
في حياتي قال كمال السنانيري لم اره في
حياتي قط
ولا خارجي انا اتقبض عليها اللي قبض عليها
اللي كان موجود في وقعت القبض عليه اللي
اول الم على وجه على كورنيش النيل في مصر
القديمه
الادار قاعد معايا في السجن الان عن
الاعلان
تواجدوا في التحقيقات وانت بتسمع الصراخ
المعذبين يعني هو اللي ب يشرف على
السنفونيه واللي يشرف على حكايه ما كانش
حد اللبنانيه ولا حد ك انا عارف وانا اعلم
انت ولا حد يملك ان يعرف السنيه اللي يشرف
عليه
من السجون اه مبارك خاضعه لاشراف امن
الدوله انا ما كنت سبقوا حقق مع اي من
المتهمين في قضيه اغتيال السادات كنت مشرف
عام على كيفيه مواجهه هذه التنظيمات تنفيذ
موعد للتحقيق ثلاث مجموعات من
ضباط اخرين وكان بيعرض عليه نتائج التحقيق
بتاعتهم وكنا بن عقد اجتماع يومي للتنسيق
مع المحققين والوضع خطه للتحقيق في الايام
القادمه انما انا شخصيا لم اكن اشترك في
ايا من التحقيقات هذه الحلول
نفى اللواء فؤاد علام وجود ايه علاقه له
بالتحقيقات التي اجريت مع السنانير دفعنا
للتساؤل عن سبب التحقيق الذي اجراه هو
شخصيا مع شقيق السنانيري في الثاني عشر من
شهر ابريل نيسان عام الف وتسعمائه واثنين
وثمانين
وبالعوده الى اوراق التحقيق نجد ان اللواء
فؤاد علام كان يريد معرفه ظروف استلام جثه
محمد كمال السنانيري وان ظهرت عليها ايه
اثار للتعذيب
ما فيش نظام سياسي معتمد شي على التعليم
في وجود سواء نظام مبارك او نظام السادات
او غير ذلك
ناصر انما كان السادات اخذهم حده في مساله
التعليم وكان اشدهم يشهدون يعني نظام
مبارك كانت الشديد وكان جهاز الخاصه امن
الدوله 1 24
حريته في التعامل كان اقوى الاجهزه
الموجوده اقول ان يقوم ال قبل الذريه
واقول المخابرات واقول العامه وكان دائما
هذا الجهاز له الاولويه في الميزانيه خاصه
ولا تعمل الخاص
ام
بالليل يوم
قبل النقل ساعه تقريبا على كمان الواحد
احنا مثلا اليوم بس كمان السنين
عشره بالليل
واحنا واحنا بتعمل وعرفنا بعد السجن
استقبال
للتعذيب لتعذيب الناس القتل وال السادات
والاحداث الصوت وكده وكانت هذه هي يعني
بدايه النهايه نشير
وضعتنا نتائج التحقيقات الصحفي محمد عبد
القدوس امام فرضيه ثانيه تتعلق ب حيثيات
وفاه القيادى الاخوانى محمد كمال
السنانيري في سجن استقبال طره فقد توصل
التحقيقات عبد القدوس الى ان السنانيري قد
قتل جراء التعذيب وليس كما اعلنت مباحث
امن الدوله المصريه بانه شنق نفسه في دوره
مياه السجن
[موسيقى]
ام
اه
[موسيقى]
اول الناس اللي شوفوا شوفوا الست وان كان
منطقه
كل ما كان في الاول
واليوم اجمعوا على انه مات شهيدا ولم
ينتهي
انه كان فيه تعذيبا وده الى موت فلان
لانه الهيئه عشان يموت
مشاهدي فرصه ل شهود يكونوا موجودين يشوفوا
التعذيب لكن لما يبقى الشعب من الاخوان
ناخذ شهادته لانه زي ما انت حضرتك
المذكرات والذكريات فيها ذاتيه وفيها
تبرير فيها مبالغه اللي استلموا البوس مين
كانوا اثنين ال الدكتور عزمي بشاره رحمه
الله عليه ابنه او اختراق كمال الثمانيه
ومحمد شو اسم ان يرى اللي هو اخو كمال
السنين يوم استلام الاسم ان من مشرحه
زينهم
رحت انا وال
الدكتور سنتين
وخاليه
والدي يسمحوا لنا بالدخول حضور الغسل
والكفن واستلام القصه كما استدعت هم
الاثنين واجريت معاهم تسجيلات
باقرار منهم انهم موافقين على هذا التسجيل
ونفى وقال انه لا لم يكن فيه اي اثار
تعذيب لم استلموا القصه لم يكن فيها اي
اثار التعذيب
ال الجزء اللي احنا شفنا من القصه او
الكلمه نكشف
الجزء العلوي الواجب فيك
واه ال ال الفك كان معروف ويبدو انه هو
كان ساعات الوفاء بجده على اسنانه بصوره
انه هو بيقوم الالم وينمو ال السبب الشبهه
اللي
صارت هذا الكلام انه لم اوقع على الارض
كما السنيه رحمه الله عليك انه دائما
الارض كانت مبلله بالمياه فما م على
منهم في المياه
كله اللحيه تبقى ملتصقه ب يعني بين انهى
فيها عمليه تصور البعض يعني
كنت في هذا الشان نوع من انواع التعذيب
وجهل المرحوم قبل السنين
ويبدو وكانه اه زي ما يكون واحد مساله
هيئه وزي ما يكون واحد مثلا الصعق
بالكهرباء
اي حاجه الفزع كان بين على وجه وبالتالي
بين انه
بالفعل نفى محمد شوقي السنانيري تعرض
شقيقه للتعذيب او انه وجد لحيته من توفي
في افادته مع فؤاد علام
واكد على ذلك في خطاب وجهه الى مجله
الدعوه الكويتيه والتي نشرت في عددها
الصادر في شهر ديسمبر كانون الاول عام الف
وتسعمائه وواحد وثمانين ان السنانير قد
تعرض للتعذيب ونتف لحيته مما ادى الى
وفاته قتلا وقد وصف شوق السنين ادعاء
المجله بالاقتراع في كمان السني لا خبرني
ان هو اه عباره عن هو يقول ان شقيق انتحر
وهذا غير صحيح وهذه الاعتقال هددوا بعدم
تسليم القصه اذا لم ي يعني هو قتل
يعني اي
وطبعا بعد كذا كذا يعني كذب هذا ال
الكلام وتناول الحديث
هو قتل
اظهر من
المرحله الثانيه وهو اكبر
في الجيش وكان متقاعد بعد تولي امن الدوله
وقوله تعالى دلوقتي الناس بيقولوا انه هو
[موسيقى]
احنا
قلناه او خلقنا واحنا بنقول انه هو ان
هناك تجوا بتقول تعفينا من اننا
احنا تعرض ماليه
وكتابه مضى عليه مضى على على اساس يعني
بهد الامور
مما استوقفنا في افادات محمد شوقي
السنانيري ان زوجه محمد كمال السنانيري
السيده امين قتل كانت قد اوصت شوقي وال
دكتور عزمي لدى استلامهما الجثه بعدم
تغسيل جثمان السنانيري لانه مات شهيدا
هذا الاعتقاد لدي زوجه السنانيري قادنا
للبحث حول اسباب رفض التصديق بانتحار
السلام يرى
كل الذين عرفوا الاستاذ كمال السنانيري
قرب كل التي ان زاملوه كل اصدقاءه الذين
قرؤوا عنه و سمعوا عن سيرته
يجزمون ان هذا الرجل الصنديد
مجاهد الذي اسندت اليه كل العمليات التي
تتعلق بالجهاد والقتال والفكر اه والذي
حبس و سجن في عهد عبد الناصر وع ان
التعذيب وويلاته في السجن الحربي و حمزه
البسيوني يكون لهذه القصص الاليمه عن
معاناه الاخوان لا يمكن ان يتصور انه ممكن
ينتحر ونحن ولم ينتحر انه رجل بايمان وورع
وزهد السنانيري اه
من التغيير لا يقدم على الانتحار الا في
حالات الياس الشديد
هذا الورع والتقوى وهو قد يجد ما يزين لا
والله فكره الانتحار وهو هذا الزوج وهذا
الايمان قد يجد ما يبرر لنفسه حق كما تكون
معروف من الاستقبال ومعلوله ان الاستاذ
كمال جانبك في الانسان اللي جنبه وبعد ذلك
جاء تشويش على الرجل اللجنه اه م اه اه
اثناء التحقيق
هذه شاهده من شويه
اللي
اثناء التحقيق
ام
تبنت جماعه الاخوان المسلمين روايه قتل
السنانير في سجن استقبال طره تحت التعذيب
ودعت الى اقامه صلاه الغائب على روح
الشهيد وفقا لما جاء في بيانها لكن يبقى
السؤال المطروح هنا ما هي دوافع تعذيب
السنانير التي ساقتها جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين للرجل البالغ من العمر اربعه
وستين عاما
او المرحوم قبل فان نشاط جميل جدا من اه
اثنين وسبعين لحد واحد وثمانين كان دائما
زياره للسعوديه وقطر والكويت والبحرين
وافغانستان وايران وكل المنطقه بحيث انه
هو ك كليه اه اه اه يعني علاقات متعدده في
اه اه البلاد كان هو مسؤول الاخوان على
العالم عن ملف اه افغانستان وكان لو دور
كبير جدا في امرين او ثلاث امور تحديدا
الامر الاول اللي هو المصالحه بين القبائل
التي تقتل الاتحاد السوفيتي الامر السنه
مساعده اللاجئين الامر الثالث بحث
احتياجات المجاهدين في افغانستان
بتقول انه هناك مال سنه كان بيلعب دور
للاخوان المسلمين في افغانستان بقدر ما
يمكن ان تعرف قيمه الدور اللي بيلعبوا
كمان مش بس في التقريب بين القاده بهذا
لما حصل بينهم خلافات لكن دوره في تسويق
فكره الجهاد في افغانستان في ذلك التوقيت
اه حكايه هناك ما شايفين كمان الثانيه قد
يكون وراء تشكيل الشباب الى افغانستان ومع
عفوا الناس
واحد وعايزين يعرفوا الخلافات كمان السنين
بيعمل في افغانستان رفض انه يقول ما يحدث
بالنسبه لهؤلاء الناس لاحد كان يعتبرها
الخاصه بال افغان نفسهم وليس
تخص النظام ولا غيره النظام المصري والا
ينظم الاخرى حاولوا ان ياخذوا منه اي
معلومات في دون و كانوا يعلمون عزمه فقط
اذا كان الغباء من جهاز امن الدوله في
الوقت ده اللي جابوا خرجوا
معها ويعذبوا ليس فقط في الموضوع الافغاني
ولكن حتى في الموضوع الاخواني كله معلومات
عن الاخوان وعلاقه الاخوان وما الى ذلك
علاقه جماعه الاخوان المسلمين وانا من
الناس اللي اعرف جديدا بالملف الافغاني
علاقه مشاركه انسانيه لم يكن لاكمال
السنين ولا تنظيم الاخوان كل للامانه يشكل
خطرا على تنظيم مدني سلمي لا يستخدم
السلاح ولا بيستخدم القوه السنين لم تكن
له اهميه تذكر ولم يكن لان دور في مواجهه
الدوله المصريه يستحق انه هو اه يتم اه اه
خمسه او يتم قتله وانه دور واكل وكان
محصور في
مساعدته
المجاهدين في افغانستان واذا شيء الامن
بيقول حيحصل عليه حصل عليه
من عيون ومن جواسيس ومن
اشخاص اخرى طالما انه سمير لم يعترف
ام
فانا اللي نشات في هذا الوقت انا اعتقد
انه كل مسافه مش متاكد ان ما يعني اذا لم
تكن ذاكره قد خلت انه
يعني يمكن في مش فاكر بالضبط انما اعتقد
انه كان خارج ال الجمهوريه ما كانش في هذا
الوقت لا اعرف عنه شيء
يمنع متخصص في الاخوان يعني اسمه لم يطرح
امامي الا لما اصرت عمليه اغتيال بمعنى
انه لم يكن له النشاط المكثف الظاهر زي زي
اخرين اما على ارض ومش متصور انه تجري او
تجرى مع حد في حاجه اه الاستاذ كمال
السنين بعيدا عن الاستاذ الان اللي اقدر
اقول لك انه اللي جا بس كمان السنيوره
اه
ولا مزرعه
كمان يعرفوا معي فقط وثيقه كويس اوي
من بين الملفات التي استوقفتنا في حادثه
وفاه محمد كمال السنانيري لقاء عقد في
المانيا عقب وفاه السنانير بسته اشهر يلفه
الكثير من الغموض
عقد اللقاء بين اللواء فؤاد علام
والمستشار الدكتور علي جريشه ممثلي جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين في المانيا انذاك ودار
فيه مناقشات لتفاصيل حادثه وفاه السلام
مبارك المرح المانيا في مظاهره
الموضوع كمان الثانيه هو حسني مبارك يعني
كمان اه الدكتور علي اللي كان مسؤول
للاخوان في ال منها في هذا الوقت كنت
سافرت المانيا في مقابلها في مهمه
اه مقابل بين وبين والنقاش في هذا الموضوع
و اه اه اه
اس دار نقاش كان ليس الشيخ عمر التلمساني
في السينما او في المعتقل في هذا الوقت
وانا استشهد تب عمر التلمساني وقد دخل
عملنا مكالمه تليفونيه بين على كريس
والثاني وهو في ال ال كان في اي وقت محتجز
في القصر العيني والثاني قال لي قريش ان
الكلام ده كله غلط ولا يصح صارت الحل
الحوار ومع هذا تم الاتفاق من وبين قريش
او لانه كانوا سابق اننا ابعاد الاوراق
التحقيق بالكامل على شان يشوف الموضوع
ارضنا علمنا والمال نحنا نسمع الدين اي
جهه الطبي شرعي في العالم تيجي يطلعوا
الجلسه ويعاد تشريعها وفحص ان مره
وبعد كل الاوراق ال اللي طلب كلها في هذا
شيء مع عمر التلمساني نفسه وانا ثلاثيه
منه خطاب انه استلم هذا الورق من عمر
التلمساني وانه يعني اعاد تفكيره
جاء في رد الدكتور علي جريشه على فؤاد
علام بعد اطلاعه عن الاوراق الخاصه بوفاه
السنين بان الدكتور جعجع قد بدا بمراجعه
تفكيره في الموضوع وانه يرى الكف عن الخوض
في هذه الموضوعات ودعا الى اتاحه الفرصه
لاعاده الثقه الكامله في نفوس الجميع كان
اللافت في الامر ان جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين لم تتقدم بايه بلاغات لكشف
النقاب عن ملابسات وفاه السنانير انذاك
ولم تسعى لاثاره الموضوع قضائيا
هذا الموقف الغريب لجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين حدا بالكثيرين الى الحديث عن
صفقه دارت بين نظام حسني مبارك وجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين عقب لقاء المانيا وفي ظل
الاتفاق مبارك وبين الاخوان
تقريبا من ضمن الصفقات دخول البرلمان
سبعه وثمانين على قوائم التحالف الذي اطلق
على التحالف الاسلامي وقد رفعت المحبوب
كان هو مهندس هذا التحالف وكان اعتقد
كنظام مبارك مع الاخوان كان يسمع العسل كل
اللي كان ب يظهر فى الصوره دى بيظهر من
افراد حسن النيه نمشي علاقه بمساله ولذلك
لا يمكن تحديد واحد يا اخوان حضر ودفاعا
عن
ومنهم
هناك تفاهمات جرت بين الاخوان وبين نظام
حسني مبارك
هذه التفاهمات
ترتب عليها اطلاق مجموعه الاخوان اللي
كانت موجوده عليها منذ ايام
اخر لكن اخرى يعني الاستاذ عمر التلمساني
اتيحت الفرصه للاخوان ينظموا صفوفهم من
جديد
اه دخل الاخوان في التحالفات السياسيه
ترتب عليها دخولهم مجلس الشعب بنواب خمسه
ثمنطاشر
خمسه وخمسين ثمانيه وثمانين
استاذ عمر الخمسين رحمه الله كان
السنين يتحد لكن عارف هو موش العام في ايه
اللي هو دخل في المعركه مع الحكومه عشان
ال اه امن الدوله عشان موضوع كمان السنيه
المتحده على الكلفه
الاخوان لا تقيم صفقه على احد من الاخوان
او غير الاخواني هذا لا يقبله الله سبحانه
وتعالى ولا تخبره اي نفس
استمرت جماعه الاخوان المسلمين في صمتها
الرسمي حيال قضيه وفاه السنانير داخل سجن
استقبال طره خمسه وعشرين عاما ف في شهر
سبتمبر ايلول عام الفين وسته وخلال ندوه
عقدت داخل نقابه الصحفيين نظمتها لجنه
الحريات التي كان يتراسها الصحفي محمد عبد
القدوس وجه الدكتور محمد حبيب النائب
الاول لمرشد جماعه الاخوان المسلمين اول
اتهام مباشر ورسمي الى اللواء فؤاد علام
المسؤوليه الكامله عن وفاه السنانير داخل
السجن
حاولنا التواصل مع الدكتور محمد حبيب لكنه
رفض مقابلتنا والاجابه عن الاسئله مما
يفتح مزيدا من التساؤلات حول هذا الصمت
المستمر حتى هذه اللحظه
في الوقت الذي تنشده كان تجدد الموضوع
نشرت روايات كثيره ودخلت انا ايضا في
مناظرات مع اللوفر الاعلام وقتها اعلنت عن
نيته تقديم بلاغ وانا الحقيقه يعني يمكن
مع السنين انا لست متذكرا الان الان انت
البلاغ ولا لكن الاغلب في وجهه نظري انني
رايته الاخوان قدموا طلب الاحاطه
وان هناك اخرين من الاخوان اعلنوا عن
نواياهم في تقديم بلاد اه اه ال لو اكتشفت
وبعد فتره انا الاخوان لم يقدموا اه هذا
البلاء وكانت ال اه يعني الوقت قد دفع
ومضى متمنين لالفين وسته واحد وثمانين ب
الفين وست
التفاهمات اللي كانت بين النظام حسني
مبارك وبين الاخوان
كانها يكبرها
اثبات ان تعذيبا وقع في عهده حسني مبارك
وان مسؤولا امنيا كبيرا والذي اشرف عن
التعذيب وهو الذي اودى بحياه الرجل الكبير
المسن اه الاستاذ مارسها الراي وما بين
اللي تكلم في الموجوده محمد حبيب محمد عبد
القدوس
الثاني والثالث والرابع من كانوا فيها
المرحوم قبل الثاني لم
يقله بالاولاد
فحتى لو اى حد من ارحب يرفع دعوه او يلتهم
الاخر ممكن انه يوصف انه هو غير ذي صفه
لانه ما اولا ما عندناش دليل يعني كله
كلام اه سواء من هنا ومن هنا كله كلام
دعايه وضعيه مضاده ما فيش اي اثنيه او
مستندات او ادله
الذي يثبت ان اللواء فؤاد علام كان موجوده
على مسرح الجريمه
الشهادات
المعتقل الالاف عشرات المعتقلين
اللي كان بيحقق معهم اللي اللي كان يشرف
على
بعض المعتقلين اكدوا على انه تم تعزيز
كمان سنين ا حتى سقط اه م خطوات
طيب انا دوله الاخوان المسلمين
ما فيش فيهم احد من تيار اخر شهد كلهم ان
نقول المسلمين او المؤيدين لهذا التيار
قدمتم البلاغ وافرج عن محمد حبيب محمد عبد
القدوس
فاكر كفاله بدايه الدليل
انه هو نفسه قدم بلاغ
ضد المستشار علي جريشه
يتهموا فيه انه بيسبوا بياخذوا بين ست الى
وقائع غير صحيحه تتعلق بالتعذيب وال كمال
السنانيري
ولم توجه الدعوه الجنائيه ضد المستشار ان
دليل على انه عاجزه عن اثبات في دوره في
واقعه تعذيب ووفاه الاستثمار انت لما تقول
الكلام دا
ما يقدرش انه هو
يحكم بانه تم
اغتيال الاوقات
السلام يرى في السجن كل هذه الادله اما
مردود عليها او انها ضعيفه
ام
لما الاخ الى الحكم
في اكثر من برنامج وتحدثت انهم يقولوا اي
حاجه هذا الموضوع مره ثانيه وكان فيه من
النائب العام يعني ممكن جدا هم اللي
بيانين وبالتاكيد كان حيبقى يعني قادر على
انه ينظروا الحقيقه بالكامل كما بلغ ويسلي
ومعملوش اجراء ملف
التحقيق في واقعه
قتلى الاستاذ كمان يعني بس وقت وقامت في
غموض يحيط بالموضوع سقوط الاخوان عن
الموضوع
عدم تحقيق هم
الملف اه قيادي في الاخوان المسلمين اه
هذه الجريمه لا تسقط بالتقادم
البعض كان يستنكر ان الاخوان لماذا لم
يفتح وهذا الملف الفتره الثانيه حكمه محمد
اذا كان الملف الاقرب وهو ملف شهداء ثوره
يناير
كل اللي عمل لجنه واللجنه كانت بالتقرير
قوي انا اعرف ممتاز جدا لكن هذا التقرير
تم اخفاء ولا نتيجه تعرضها لضغوط من اجهزه
الامن لسوائل الشرطه او غير ذلك والا جهاز
السيد تعرضت لضغوط وكانوا حقيقه يعني ليس
بيدهم شيء ولا يحكمون تقارير الامن احنا
ما بنشوف تقارير الامن
ومؤكد انه في تقرير كتبت عن
المساله
وفاه خلينا نستخدم تعبير وفاه محمد كمال
الدين الثانيين في السيد واكد الفتره الى
ال ال الامن الامن وهو موجوده المحافظين
الى ان تظهر تقارير وسائل اخرى ستظل هذه
القضيه معلقه بهذا الشكل ما فيش مقتول في
عهد مبارك
خالص مع ان عددهم مائه قتيل
انه ما فيش حد اطلاقا اه تحقق تعذيبا او
اهمالا او مرض او غير ذلك هذه الجريمه قتل
الاستاذ كمال السنانيري لم تسقط بمضى
المده ولا
ولا يحميها اي قانون ان الفرصه مازالت
متاحه وان على الاخوان المسلمين او اي احد
ان يقدم بلاغ حول هذه الواقع الان لابد ان
يصاحبها بشهادات
وب ادله انما كلام مرسل انما من الممكن ان
تعاد ان يعاد فتح الملف من جديد اه من
الممكن قانونا يجوز نعم قانون نيوز
الموضوع لازم تفتحوا تفاصيل وتعرف مش عشان
ال ال ال صار وعلى ال ال ضغط الدم ولا هو
موضوع ال الحقيقه ولا شيء غير الحقيقه
طبعا للروايه الرسميه فقد اقدم السنانير
على الانتحار في دوره مياه السجن شنقا
بربط احد اطراف غطاء السرير حول رقبته
والطرف الاخر بشيء مرتفع في الحمام حيث
تدلي و اختنق حتى سقط ارضا ليجده حراس
السجن في الصباح وقد فارق الحياه
ولكن بعد التدقيق في الروايات والوثائق
التي حصلنا عليها اعدنا نسج خيوط الحكايه
في محاوله لكشف غموض ما حصل ليله وفاه
السنانيري رغم غياب الشهود على لحظه وفاته
بدت اكثر الروايات صلابه هي التي اوضحت ان
السلام يرى استدعى منفردا ليله وفاته بطلب
من اداره السجن لسبب مجهول
حيث شاهده عدد من رفاقه من الفتحات الضيقه
ل لسنا زين وبعضهم تحدث اليه وكانت هذه
اخر مره يراه احد منهم على قيد الحياه قبل
ان تعلن وفاته في اليوم التالي
وباتفاق معظم الشهود على انهم تعرضوا
للتعذيب داخل السجن بمن فيهم السنانير
تكون فكره موته اثناء التعذيب اكثر
الروايات ترجيحا ولكن لا يعرف حتى اللحظه
من كان المسؤول عن ذلك ولا كيف حصلت
الوفاه بالضبط
ام
ام ام
[موسيقى]
اه
ام